One thing I love is submitting to my husband
And not in an oppressive/toxic way,
but in a we honor each other with love and devotion,
I'm being taken care of kind of way.
I'm not bashing other people who don't believe this,
if you disagree,
that is your right.
But there’s something so special when you find a good man that's fully devoted to you,
this is what a lot of women want,
even when the world pressures you to be independent,
I hear other women say all the time,
“just wait until you get older”
or “who's gonna tell her”
But if this is what I value and other people value,
why are we putting past relationship pain onto others?
A woman's scorn is so valid
but I love submitting to my partner so he can properly lead us
and I know I'll be happy.
I’m not ashamed to say that I like traditional gender roles.
I'm a woman who has long hair,
I like to cook,
clean, and nurture the ones I love.
And I love being who I am.
I think we should honor and respect being a housewife,
but I also don't think that we need to tear down workforce women either.
Everyone should pursue what's right for their lives.
true feminism doesn't or (shouldn't) care what other women do with their lives
Radical feminist will demonize any woman
who says that she wants to be a stay at home wife
and live by traditional roles in her marriage or household
All I’m saying if you enjoy traditional roles; cooking,
cleaning, etcetera,
then you shouldn't be ashamed of it
do whatever makes you happy.